hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand final of the magnus calls in
chester we are in match four
uh match three was won by magnus so now
it's two to one uh
in matches for magnus so if magnus wins
this one then he
uh wins the match and he goes to the
finals to meet the winner of the hikaru
uh versus daniel dubov match-up now it's
uh
again quite the game magnus was
victorious in game one it was it was a
pretty nice grind with the white pieces
and now
we have this one where ding has the
white piece so this is game two
of match four uh so uh let's check it
out as this one is really a beauty
so uh for those of you who are asking uh
why i'm in the new setup i'm on vacation
and i will be until 21st of august uh so
that's why i'm here i'm using my laptop
i don't have my
uh original setup that i use at home and
i
some of you said that uh the sound was a
bit off in the previous video that the
microphone was too low that the sound of
the
you know moves was too loud so i tried
to
improve on it in this video hope it's i
hope it's better now
but yeah returning to the game uh it's
uh ding versus magnus and the ding opens
with
d4 we have knight to f6 by magnus
we have c4 and g6 magnus goes for the
king's indian defense we have g3
adding prepares to finca to the light
square bishop and bishop to g7
bishop to g2 and magnus castles uh with
knight to c3 and d6 preparing to strike
in the center with e5 at some point with
knight to f3
and knight to c6 we have castles by
ding and we have e5 finally by magnus
and the d5
grabbing more space in the center as one
will usually do against the king's
indian defense
knights the e7 and now e4 so grabbing
the center
and next you want to play rogue b1 you
want to go a3 a4
a4 b4 and push on the queen side c5 and
so on and black of course will try to
play on the king's side and here uh
the most often move used is knight to d7
you want to free your uh
uh f file for for the push of the f-pawn
and there are over 300 games in the
database where this exact
maneuver happen however magnus goes for
b6 and it's a
it's an extremely rare move it was used
a few times uh one
more notable game is from the 1950
uh from the 1950s uh panov used it
against igram petrosian and he was able
to defeat him
and was quite quite a beautiful
attacking game so as magnus is a big fan
of the classics i i imagine he
uh took some looks and at this game and
maybe found
found some not maybe of course found
some improvements uh but okay rook b1
bing will continue pushing
on the queen side and a5 magnus prevents
the immediate b4
and here we have rook to e1 uh so this
is the difference in the
petrossian versus spawn of gaming 1950
a3 a3 was played but here
we have rook to e1 biting and it is of
course as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so let's see what
happens here knight d7 again magnus
needs to free up the df file for the f
pawn
with a a3 now preparing b4 and h6
uh with knight the h4 by ding ding wants
to control the f5 square he knows f5 is
coming so the knight and the pawn
controller queen is coming to c2 to help
out with the control of the f5 square
so f5 immediately while it's still
possible uh he
captures g captures black messes up his
spawn structure in front of the king but
it is something you will
very often do when you go for the king's
indian defense and now you
will continue pushing so queen c2
puts pressure uh on the f5 pawn and
knights to f6 now now the bishop will
also help out with the defense the
knight as well
uh e4 will be pushed at some point to
continue pushing free of the dark square
bishop and so on
so b4 as like we said
white will continue pushing on the queen
side bishop d7 by magnus
and the now c c5 so we have eight
captures on b4
it captures and now finally e4 because
this puts a lot of pressure
on the e5 pawn since this one defends it
uh uh
magnus decides to advance it with e4
and now c6 and this is now a pretty
pretty closed
position on the queen side uh and you
have to decide what to do bishop to c8
looks a bit ugly if b5 is played at some
point
that bishop is never coming out of that
uh
of that uh well uh tomb uh so bishop to
e8 you can now shift it to this diagonal
if
if neither you can shift it to this
diagonal if needed uh wow those are some
weird arrows
uh and uh also your d5 point is under
attack so here
uh ding decides to go for f3 he gives up
the d5 point
uh pick up the uh the e and f pawn and
open up the position since
his king is a little bit safer than
carlson's king so we have knight f
captures on d5 magnus does accept this
with knight captures knight captures and
f captures on e4 captures followed by
captures and now
uh magnus needs to do something about
this his knight is under attack he needs
to move it and
he decides to go for not back with
knight to f6 but rather he goes
knights to c3 attack the rook puts
pressure on the bishop makes sense you
want to trade up
as much as possible and then you will
probably bring the queen into the game
bring the rook into the game
as the bishop nicely defends it and so
on however this
uh gives ding an opportunity for a
beautiful attacking move
uh and an idea so feel free to pause the
video while i give you a couple of
seconds
uh and find this uh brilliancy
uh you know while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
taking your opponent into a deep dark
forest and for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's bishop
captures on h6 and here
uh all of king's defenses have been
shattered and the question is what
can you do here what is there any move
that you can play
so well obviously there are ideas of
course you can capture the rook on b1
let's say you try capturing the rook
the problem is with capturing the rook
uh everything is forced from here
bishop to h7 check king h8 and now you
pick up the bishop here
rook captures here and now it doesn't
matter if the rook captures or the queen
captures if the rook captures then you
get a nice knife g6 check king h7 you're
gonna go knight to the f8 to check
and now it doesn't matter king g8 you're
gonna go queen h7 check
king captures and queen captures and g7
would mate
so that's what happens if the uh rook
captures here if the queen captures
however
not much different you're just gonna go
still knight g6 checking h7 you're gonna
capture the rook now with
check and now if you go back it's the
same same idea
or if you go uh capturing the bishop
then it's queen h7 check
you're going to go to g5 queen h4 check
king to f5 and now queen to f4 will be
checkmate as the knight covers
g6 and e6 so pretty pretty wild stuff
so after this knight the c3 move of
course capturing the the rook is not
possible
so what happens if after bishop captures
an h6 you go bishop d for
check first you don't allow any captures
on g7
let's say uh white retreats bishop e3
now we trade uh one of white's attackers
captures captures and then captured the
rook
uh it still doesn't work because now
it's bishop to d5 check and
this is just uh amazing what happens
here king g7
now queen to b to check and black even
gets to block it with the queen
however knights the f5 check and now uh
it all depends if you go let's say king
to g6 then it's
rook to e6 just winning the queen as of
course the bishop here uh
guards this but the more beautiful idea
is after king to h7
now rook to e7 check and now what
what do you do here uh well you you can
even either give up the queen or you can
go king to h8 and
now there's the real the real beauty now
looked at e6 and this is just incredible
you can't move the queen as the queen is
spinned so one thing you can do
is capture the queen on c2 but then the
problem is rook to h6 is checkmate as
these two squares are covered by the
knight and by the bishop
so whatever magnus does here is just
completely losing so
uh what else can you do after bishop
captures an h6
you could capture with this but then the
knight is just undefended and then you
know it's uh
the game continues with white being so
much better he just uh
grabbed the pawn he he he traded well i
mean all of
white's pieces are are placed
beautifully and it's just gonna be
a very very hard position for black to
play so what
carlson did after bishop captures he
played queen to f6 first
now the knight is defended there is more
pressure on the bishop
and you've developed one more piece into
the game however there's also
a problem here because here ding goes
bishop to h7
check king the h8 and now again rook
captures eliminating the light square
bishop is crucial because you need
this g6 square available for your knight
we have rook captures uh you could
ignore it by playing bishop captures
again but then again a rookie seven is
just deadly i mean it's just a
disgustingly beautiful move if queen
captures then knight
check uh picks up the queen and if you
don't capture it there's really no
defense against knight to g6 the king
has nowhere to go
and ig6 is coming so this is uh if you
capture with
with the bishop so rook f chapter 78 was
played but now
knight the g6 checked by ding king
captures an h7
and now knights the f8 check and again
if you go up then it's queen to h7
check king to f7 uh or doesn't really
matter what you do
and now rook to f1 uh i mean wins the
queen where where you capture the knight
or not so
it doesn't really matter and even if
captures captures and captures
you do gain some material back but now
just bishop captures and everything is
hanging
there are some discoveries this is
hanging this is hanging so it's just
game over
so here after knight to f8 check king
captures an h6 was played but now ding
goes in for the kill
queen to h7 check king to g5
and now queen to h4 check and like in
the previous variation the knight here
guards the g6 and e6 squares
so king f5 and of course being delivers
queen to f4 and this
is now checkmate so incredible game by
being incredible that
we see a nice beautiful checkmate on the
board with
the world champion being checkmated with
his king and f7 on f5
and with this uh with this game adding
equalizes match four
uh so we'll see uh two more games in the
rapids two more games of blitz and then
maybe armageddon we'll see how it goes
today i will probably be able to cover a
bit uh a few more games uh but if not
you know
uh see you again tomorrow uh so yeah
that's uh the game i do hope you enjoyed
it i'm sure magnus
magnus hasn't i would like to thank
paula [ __ ] larse evan alamos
um stephen stephen ramsey daniel narlow
and thomas connors for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the grand
final of the magnus
crossing chester checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day
and middle of course says hi hello
such a good boy see you soon